so something caught my eye this week did
you see this it was an official meeting
in Europe of the Paris climate Accord
process which of course president Trump
ruled America out of look what happened
when a US Representative took the stage
to explain our position if we are
serious about eradicating poverty in
providing universal access to affordable
reliable energy it is clear that energy
innovation and fossil fuels will
continue to play a leading role very
strange you know how climate change
activists never stopped going on about
believing the science and how facts
matter well then why are they cheering
the United States instead of cheering in
the evil populace Trump's America here's
what happened to energy-related carbon
emissions in 2017 they fell by not 0.5%
but in the saintly globalist European
Union they went up by 1.5 percent in the
same period in fact per capita carbon
emissions in Trump's America are nearly
at a 17-year low turns out energy
deregulation does more to fight climate
change than going to conferences I guess
you might call that An Inconvenient
Truth there's a lot of those about this
one's pretty inconvenient if you're the
kind of person that goes around saying
Trump is a fake populist that he's not
doing anything to help the Forgotten men
and women in this country all he had
time for was celebrities and now
suddenly he's acting like he's a
populist out there man I'm gonna fight
for working people come on man he's
trying to tell us he cares about the
middle class give me a break that's a
bunch of malarkey Malaki I won't joke
Joe Biden to run just in 2020 just so we
hear more of that word but look
America's poverty rate was lower in
Trump's first year than at any point in
the Obama administration okay whatever
but of course the middle class was
screwed by the Trump tax cuts that only
helped the rich right oh wait the Trump
tax cuts doubled the standard deduction
to $12,000 for individuals in 24,000 for
families that is a huge change that
takes millions of Americans out
federal income tax altogether and has
effectively increased incomes for
middle-class families across the country
what else helps the middle class jobs
but of course that idiot Trump couldn't
create them when somebody says like the
person you just mentioned who I'm not
going to advertise for that he's gonna
bring all these jobs back well how
exactly are you gonna do that he just
says well I'm gonna I'm gonna negotiate
a better deal well ha what how exactly
are you going to negotiate that what
magic wand do you have yet Trump what
magic wand er you have I don't know
maybe just better economic policy the
kind that results in the lowest
unemployment rate since 1969 and the
lowest african-american unemployment
ever also wasn't Trump gonna crash the
economy economist left right and center
all agree
Donald Trump will drive America back
into recession left right and center
Inconvenient Truth Hillary even the New
York Times I think left just gave Trump
credit for the fact that the US economy
is on track for its quote best annual
performance since 2005 all right
whatever jobs and growth but Trump still
isn't delivering his promises to working
people I mean after decades of
stagnation incomes are still flat aren't
they do you think that we've been
looking at for quite a while that
doesn't seem to be moving too much is
weighed or wages oh dear that turns out
not to be true anymore
wages have risen all the way through the
last two years and we're up 3.1 percent
in the last quarter the highest level in
a decade fine but it's all going to be
ruined isn't it by Trump's crazy trade
war with China in fact the elitists
seemed to hate Trump so much they even
took China's side remember how they
thrilled for the brutal autocrat Xi
Jingping at Davos last year they just
lapped up his speech on the virtues of
globalization the president of the EU
owned european investment banks said in
these times of a lack of leadership
particularly in europe it was quite
impressive ooh
President Xi you're quite impressive but
what's actually happening
is that president Trump's pressure is
working China is on the back foot making
trade concessions and now pledging to
drop It's Made in China 2025 program
which was Xi Jinping's grand plan to
achieve world domination in the
industries of the future we'll see if
they mean it but even the fact that
they're saying it is a major victory for
that idiot trump who obviously doesn't
know what he's doing
just like with North Korea remember we
have what I think the total is seventy
one hundred individual nuclear warheads
I don't even want to know
the destructive capability is there and
we're about to hand the launch orders
over to a guy who can't stay away from
his phone for 15 minutes he was outgoing
President Obama who told president-elect
Donald Trump that North Korea would be
his number one problem Trump actually
listened to him did something about it
and turned our relationship around in a
way that has made the world incomparably
safer and then just this week we saw
incredibly important substantive
progress from this administration major
criminal justice reform led by Jared
Kushner now looking good for passage in
the Senate a major new effort to
revitalize urban America and rebuild
low-income neighborhoods led by ben
Carson and a highly significant new
strategy from John Bolton to fight
China's attempted colonization of Africa
on top of that America this week
becoming a net oil exporter for the
first time in 75 years enabling us to
reduce the global influence of dodgy
regimes in the Middle East and elsewhere
yeah but he's still an idiot though
isn't he still Trump look the point here
is this will never persuade the Trump
haters on the left and the right to
change their feelings about the
president they just can't stand him but
more than anything it's aesthetic they
find him vulgar not to their taste fine
but could you just focus on the facts
could you just acknowledge even for a
day or so over Christmas that on the
facts on policy on this substance this
is so far a pretty successful presidency
tell me what you think of that at an
x-ray of FNC
and that Steve Hilton X